football's european governing body uefa
is under attack
12 of the continent's biggest clubs have
announced they're breaking away from the
prestigious champions league
to form a rival european super league
barcelona real madrid and atletico
have agreed to join from spain in italy
both ac and inter milan have signed up
alongside juventus
and six clubs from england's premier
league also want a slice of the pie
manchester united manchester city
liverpool
chelsea arsenal and tottenham the owners
of the club
now wants much much more
revenues for them the pandemic obviously
have exposed them too much so they want
much more money and they want it now so
far there are no teams from france or
germany
including the current european champions
bayern munich but three more clubs are
expected to join the list of founding
members
who are all set to pocket more than 400
million dollars each just for signing up
seriously in the midst of a pandemic an
economic crisis
football clubs at national league level
going bust nearly
furloughing players clubs on the edge in
league one and two and these
are having zoom calls about breaking
away and basically creating more greed
joke the managers of these teams are now
in an awkward position
liverpool's jurgen klopp for example has
previously spoken out against the idea
of a super league
manchester united's oleg nasolsky dodged
the question
at his news conference on sunday i don't
think it's
for me to comment on now it's an issue
we'll just have to wait and see what
happened there was a similar defensive
response from atletico madrid's coach
diego
i'm just a manager and i'm prepared to
coach my players under any circumstances
i have no doubt that the club will
decide what's best for ourselves
the super league clubs want to start as
soon as possible while still competing
in their own national leagues
that seems unlikely though given that
the premier league la liga and serie a
have all joined uefa in condemning the
move saying they'll do whatever it takes
to stop it
world governing body fifa has also said
that any players who take
part will be barred from their major
competitions including the world cup
four thousand fans were allowed into
wembley for the fa cup semi-final on
sunday
and some of them made their views clear
on the super league
when you take a league and you make a
bit of a closed shop
it's just completely unfair it seems
like a lot of the big boys don't like
the idea of smaller clubs great crashing
their party and taking away some of
their revenue it's all money orientated
and everything load of coswallow
uefa's executive committee meets on
monday the super league announcement has
no doubt added a few things to the
agenda
david stokes al jazeera
let's bring in ap's global sports
correspondent rob harris live
from london rob it's all happening first
of all what do we know about
jose mourinho being sacked at tottenham
yeah he's lasted only 17 months in
charge of a familiar picture of player
feuds and various disputes within the
club that have really escalated through
this season
a season when at one point it looked
like they could be on for the title
they're
in top first place in december but
they've completely collapsed
also exited the fa cup the europa league
and now lies seventh in the premier
league but mourinho's exit comes just
days before he was due to potentially
have it well he's gonna have a chance to
end tottenham's trophy drought going
back to 2008 and he's missed out on a
chance to take
on manchester city in the league cup
final tottenham chairman daniel leaving
levy recognizing that's been a difficult
period for
jose mourinho and tottenham during the
pandemic of the last year or so
but ultimately he goes out having failed
to restore tottenham to even the
position they were under mauricio
pochettino
and uh he leaves uh one of the shortest
the shortest spell of his managerial
career
since the early days of it okay
tottenham are one of the clubs that are
part of the super league story and there
have been further developments today
already
where do we stand on that well this was
the
big announcement yesterday with the
clubs announcing their breakaway
and the opposition has grown
particularly from fans of those
clubs that would be part of this new
elite clique but
the threats have been piling in uefa
have said that they would be
banned from competing in their domestic
leagues as things stand they wouldn't be
allowed to take part to the players in
international competitions with their
national teams
and in the last few hours as well i've
seen a letter that the super league
clubs have sent to
the uefa and fifa leadership saying they
themselves have started their own
legal proceedings not said where but to
force through
this plan to get the super league
breakaway very strange in the letter
they say
they recognize and accept the existence
the ongoing existence of the champions
league
but of course it'd be a champions league
without some of its biggest
clubs if uh these elite do go ahead with
the breakaway it's ultimate brinkmanship
with uh uae for over just who controls
the champions league
yeah and and the super league looks like
the format would be based on an american
sports model could you explain to our
viewers what this might actually look
like
yeah so currently the champions league
is 32 teams all the teams have to
qualify through their domestic league
finishes unless they've won the
champions league the previous year
they were due to expand that to 36 teams
from 2024
what this super league envisages is a 20
team format
with 15 founding members who'd be
guaranteed entry each year didn't matter
how they did if they were in their
domestic leagues
still each season only 12 clubs have
signed up so far they're hoping for
another
three spots but um the plan is for
a um a significant group stage splitting
the
uh teams into two groups and then with a
quite traditional format as we expect
now going into a quarterfinals
uh as two legs likewise the semi-final
in a single game
final they aim to start it as soon as
possible and it's very hard to imagine
them even competing in the champions
league still this season you've got
you've got them still in contention for
this season's competition
uh to know so that is going to be a
significant
move in the coming days and weeks and
today with uefa meeting
that uh it's going to be interesting to
hear what they actually say for new way
for leadership in public on the day they
still hope to announce their new own
expanded champions league format
okay rob harris thank you for that we'll
speak to you again soon